hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from round three of this
year's Fay World rapid Championship it
just finished it is Magnus Carlson
versus Armenian
grandmas tigran petan named obviously or
maybe it's not obvious but I'm guessing
he was named after uh the former world
champion petan and uh we we even have a
couple of U Indian Grand Masters called
Anand I I know for two of them maybe
maybe there's more but yeah I'm pretty
sure in like 10 years we'll have like 20
uh Indian Grand Masters called Anand uh
so you know being a world CH Champion
will inspire uh many people uh now uh
what can he do against Magnus with the
black pieces it's a really wonderful
game you guys will enjoy this one uh
let's check it out and do use that hasht
suggestion as later on I will go through
them and check out your suggestions so
Magnus with the white pieces opens with
E4 uh Pawn to G6 going for the modern
defense we have D4 Bishop to G7 Knight
to F3 and pawn to D6 now we have Bishop
to D3 by Magnus and Knight to C6 uh C3
and the immediate Pawn to E5 we have
Pawn to D5 and Knight C to E7 uh Magnus
advances the pawn we have Pawn to C4 and
pawn to F5 getting a sort of a king's
Indian um type setup Knight to C3 and
Knight to F6 now and there are a couple
of moves that have been played here but
Magnus goes Knight G5 right away and it
is now as of move nine that we have a
completely new game so what can be done
here okay we have castles there's no
stopping Knight E6 but you of course you
will capture the Knight so it's not
really an issue we have castles and now
Pawn to C6 attacking magnus's strong
Center here uh Queen to B3 uh putting
pressure on the king uh x-ray the king
basically through this long diagonal and
also putting pressure on B7 so you can't
really develop your light Square Bishop
so first U uh tigran moves the king king
to h8 and now Bishop to D2 We have Pawn
to F4 as is customary in the the Kings
Indian and now Rook 8 to C1 we have Pawn
to C5 uh stopping Magnus from executing
Pawn to C5 and now Queen to A3 uh we
have Pawn to H6 kicking away the Knight
and Knight to E6 and of course you
capture this Knight you're not going to
give up the exchange we have captures
captures and now there are a couple of
ways you could continue this and
objectively best probably would be
Knight to H7 Shifting the Knight to G6
to go after the pawn uh and uh let's say
something like B4 is played Knight to G
five we're going to see a trade here and
after some leg Rook F to D1 now the
Knight captures on E6 and after l a
bishop B2 trying to get something on the
black queen here Knight to D4 and this
is a beautiful setup here with a very
strong Knight on D4 and now you're going
to prepare your pieces for further
pushing on the king side but uh tigran
decided to execute Pawn to F3 right away
and his idea is that well regardless of
what Magnus does he's going to capture
the pawn on E6 with the queen and get
the queen into the king side to
Checkmate the white king now can he do
this well Magnus even invites him he
plays Pawn to G3 and okay what's
stopping him from Queen captures on E6
and queen to H3 nothing really Queen to
C8 and now Magnus goes Knight to D5 okay
there is some pressure on the Knight on
E7 uh but just Queen captures on E6
defends a knight and still threatens
Queen to H3 but mag just moves The Rook
Rook to F1 or rather Rook F to E1 which
means that if Queen comes to H3 you can
kick it away with Bishop to F1
uh with Tempo and also you you guard the
the G2 Square so instead after Rook F to
E1 we have Knight E captures on D5 C
captures on D5 and now Queen to G4 a
very sneaky move uh preparing Pawn to H5
and pawn to H4 but also putting pressure
on the E4 Pawn meaning that Magnus
cannot play Bishop to F1 as the E4 Pawn
will be undefended but Magnus sees
through right right through this and he
plays Bishop to F1 nonetheless the point
is uh that if you capture with the
Knight then Rook the to C4 and you
blunder that Knight so that's not
possible so instead after Bishop to F1
we have Pawn to B6 sorry that's not a B6
Pawn to B6 and now Pawn to H3 kicking
away the queen queen H5 and now Pawn to
B4 as usual uh black will play on the
king side in the king's Indian and white
will play on The Queen Side Pawn to G5
with have B captures on C5 B captures
and queen to A6 now putting pressure on
the weak D6 Pawn if you can eliminate it
then you get a pass D Pawn and your
winning chances improve drastically and
now you could go for something like Rook
F to d8 and sort of keep this Rook
defending the A7 Pawn but you really
don't need it since if the A7 Pawn is
captured you can just move the Rook back
and go after the A2 Pawn so he just
moves The Rook to d8 uh and now Rook to
B1 not rushing with any captures we have
Pawn to G4 and the Magnus stops the
advancement with Pawn to H4 we have
Queen to G6 freeing up the H5 Square for
the Knight and the bishop to A5 now
going after the Rook the other Bishop
will of course take away the light
squares and then the D6 Pawn will fall
there's no stopping this so Rook to
D7 and Bishop to B5 by Magnus we have
Rook D to F7 doubling up on the f file
uh but you're not really doubling up
towards something you you're doubling up
towards your F3 pawn and okay maybe if
you can get your knight here capture on
G3 maybe if white captures maybe you can
play F2 those are a lot of maybe so here
Queen captures on D6 and now Queen to H5
of course now Knight to H 5 is
impossible as a queen trade it's not
even a queen trade black will blund a
queen so Queen to H5 and now Bishop back
to C3 assuming this strong diagonal but
also uh with the direct threat of queen
or Bishop captures on E5 so Knight H7
and now the bishop defends on E5 as well
and Bishop back to F1 uh we have Bishop
to F6 now trying to get some sort of um
game here maybe even just sacrifice a
piece uh Rook to B5 Magnus goes after
the C5 point as well he says the the
king side is completely blocked I'm just
going to capture everything on the queen
side push my pawns and win the game so
Knight to G5 trying to give up a a
knight for some sort of an attack but
Magnus just ignores it he says whatever
you do here you're not you can break
through your own pawns that's that
should be some something uh maybe there
is a quote about that yeah but you can't
go through your own pawns that doesn't
matter how many pieces you have the in
the attack you can't go through your own
Pawn so magic just played Rook captures
on C5 Knight stage H three with check
and he eliminates the Knight captures we
have G captures on H3 and queen to E6
now going after the pawn here and the
problem is you can't um sacrifice
anything because Queen captures on E5
check just forces a queen trade so here
King to H7 was played unpinning trying
to get some sort of an attack going but
just Queen captures on H3 and that's
pretty much it Bishop to h8 we have Pawn
to D6 Magnus starts pushing the past
Pawn Rook to G8 and now Rook to C7 and
he was in this position on move 39 that
tigran petan resigned the game as there
is nothing more to be done here whatever
you do here D7 is already covered D7 is
coming but you you can also just play
Rook to D1 push the pawn and there's no
there there's no even a threat here you
can't even double up because then black
white can also just trade but just Rook
D1 and you don't have anything you don't
have sacrifices as F DF pawn and the
queen are covering G3 you don't have uh
any sort of way of getting the bishop
into the game so there is nothing here
for black uh so yeah after drawing that
game in round one Magnus gains two
victories and we'll see if he is able to
uh to do more damage on his way to
defend his world chest championship
title uh but a lot of players are on
three out of three such as
baranor nikin
arji Naran Ian chaparo David Anon Garo
and Maxim mlov and even more Timur Gan
three out of three Alexander shimanov
Maxim chav y so those are 12 players on
three out of three absolutely incredible
and if you have a favorite played by any
of them do use that hashtag suggestion
and I will go over them at one point uh
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it a good attempt by by tigran
but at that crucial point where he
should have uh kept it cool you know
just improved his position he went for
that early F3 and you can't rush
anything against Magnus so yeah I would
like to thank Jack schroer SE Dia Isaac
Davis Martin gor pap and Timothy rosan
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot really appreciate it uh as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the FED World rapid
Championship until it finishes uh so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your
day